for today's classic interview we go back
to my interview with maybe one of the
better-known medical ethicists in the
United States today arthur caplan we
spoke about the morality of genetic
editing and there's a couple different
connections here one is that in the last
two years the advancements of the CRISPR
project have been significant and the
type of genetic editing that Arthur and
I discussed during the interview is in a
sense already a reality but going to be
mainstreamed as a possibility very very
soon and it's also been 40 years since
the beginning of in-vitro fertilization
which is not genetic editing in any of
the senses that I discussed with our
Caplan but it is in a sense sort of the
catalyst from which much of the current
medical technology around genetic
editing maybe came from in some sense so
I think what is interesting to think
about is when you watch this interview
listen to this interview I did with art
back in January of 2016
do our reviews seem almost quaintly
outdated in some way in other words have
things advanced so much in terms of our
perception of the issue of genetic
editing that a conversation that's
two-and-a-half years old seems almost
outdated in terms of modern
sensibilities back to January of 2016
when I interviewed medical ethicist
Arthur Caplan it's great to welcome back
to the program arthur caplan director of
the division of medical ethics at nyu
langone medical center we've been
talking increasingly about genetic
editing and we covered the story of the
one year old girl with leukemia whose
life was at least for the time being
saved by the first procedure we're
genetically edited cells from a donor
were implanted into her and of course as
soon as we start talking about this the
emails pauran about the ethical and
moral considerations of genetic editing
let's start at sort of the broadest
point when you think about genetic
editing what are the the moral and
ethical concerns that you have or at
least that you most frequently hear
cited well there are really two kinds of
genetic editing one is to change cells
either modify cells and put them into
the body as
was done with a little girl or to try
and use viruses to insert genetic
material into cells say someone with
cystic fibrosis who has a genetic
mistake you're trying to get viruses to
insert corrected material right into the
lungs of the person there's also genetic
editing that takes place to eliminate
diseases that are inherited there you're
trying to modify embryos you're trying
to change the DNA correct errors there
so that the disease is not passed on to
a child or to grandchildren or to any
descendants the first kind of genetic
editing is called somatic cells body
cells they're not inherited you're
fixing something in a person it's
controversial because there are
certainly safety considerations people
have died in the middle of these
experiments there's some controversy
about whether or not it's right to try
and repair diseases using genetic
engineering when we don't have enough
animal data but because some of these
diseases animals don't get them but
overall I think genetically editing body
cells is fairly widely accepted it makes
sense in that it's the individual who
has to make the choice about whether
they want to take the risk the benefits
may or may not follow people understand
when they have terrible diseases that
they may die in these experiments but
think overall the verdict has been
review them carefully make sure the
science is sound
make sure the informed consent is good
and let them proceed where you really
get pushback is when people are trying
to change embryos change things that are
passed on and that's uh that that's I've
received people who emails from people
who seem to have completely opposite
views on that some say if you're going
to make changes that would lead to
subsequent generations in other words
the children of those whose embryos are
changed not requiring the same edit in
other words eliminating something that
would be inherited that's good and
others say no no that's not
because you're actually making changes
to subsequent generations and they have
sort of no choice over that so it's
interesting that I've received feedback
from people with very very divergent
views on that particular issue well I
think when we're talking about changing
inherited DNA
yeah modifying our descendants there's
really a couple of ethical concerns that
the critics have one is you just don't
cross that line because the people
affected can't consent your future
daughter your unborn grandchild they
can't say I'll take the risk try to fix
my sickle-cell disease my hemophilia my
cystic fibrosis whatever it is I can't
give you my permission I have to say to
that objection I'm not impressed with
that worry I think parents make
decisions for children all the time we
make them for newborns all the time we
do prenatal screening all the time
absolutely that is you know people make
choices for their descendants and that's
just a reality absolutely so now that
we've said that you don't feel that that
is a strong argument against that type
of decision what does strike you as a
stronger argument there are at least one
we should pay more attention to I think
when we're talking about genetic changes
for heredity looming over that area is
the experience of Germany with eugenics
with trying to eliminate people who are
disabled weak seen as burdens on society
seen as racially inferior in our current
world that's where we're hardly over
racism bigotry in views that are anti
disability so when people say I want to
get rid of bad things in future
generations part of the argument is what
is a bad thing it's one thing to say I
don't want to pass on tay-sachs disease
okay
that's going to kill the child and it
makes sense I think it's hard to argue
against that it's another thing to say I
want to get rid of Asperger's or I'm not
sure I want to have a short child those
sorts of things are differences are they
diseases are they really
problems that make people unhappy so one
key issue then becomes identified what
it is you're talking about how do you
know when something really is a disease
or just a difference it's clearly some
people for example in the deaf community
would say being deaf isn't a disease
it's a difference we have our own
language we have our own colleges we
live happy lives we contribute to
society you don't have to eliminate
deafness that's not something you have
to genetically engineer out of the human
species then the related issue is what
about the people who say hey great as
long as we can get rid of lethal or
terrible diseases
why don't we improve ourselves why don't
we make stronger taller faster smarter
kids when you can do genetic changes
that repair disease you can also do
genetic changes that enhance or improve
quote-unquote future generations so I
think the objections that we have to pay
attention to are how do we define what
it is that we might try to fix without
getting rid of all human diversity and
just having you know some perfect
stereotype of the head quote unquote
healthy descendant and then are we ready
to go down a path that might open the
door to really try to improve our
species how would you define or how
could we as a society figure out whether
there's a sort of I don't know approved
list of what we can quote fix or change
I mean some people emailed me saying
listen David this is going to happen
sooner or later the medical community is
going to improve on these techniques
this is going to be available does it
not make more sense to regulate and sort
of have some approved list of procedures
that you can and can't do but then the
problem is who is in charge of deciding
and what would be a sort of moral and
ethical way to decide what is and is not
allowed well I think those comments are
right on point if you say Bennett no
changes nothing allowed that's
hereditary right it's not it's not going
to happen
plenty of other countries China
Singapore many places in the world are
going to be doing and using this
technology to engineer
diseases out of their children it will
take place if the United States says for
example no federal funds for embryo
engineering which right now is what
we're saying a major tool that the
government has to impose regulations to
come up with that list to designate a
panel to do it goes away there is no
federal funding there's no lever to push
on to make regulation possible so what
will happen here is a private market
rich will drive what the technology does
private companies will set up they're
not accountable to almost anyone in
terms of the services they offer by the
way that's what the infertility field
looks like today right a private market
where single people older people you
name it anybody can use the services and
the clinic's put in five embryos six
embryos Octomom etc so we know what
awaits us if we don't try to keep
government funding present in order to
in part to allow us to shape or control
the evolution of the technology look I
think it's silly to argue that we're not
going to see efforts made to get rid of
tay-sachs and breast cancer and prostate
cancer and chemo philia and many many
other heritable diseases no one is going
to hold those people hostage for very
long out of fears that we don't know
where to draw the line so we better be
ready for a world in which people at
some point if not tomorrow in a few
years start to engineer embryos to get
rid of awful clearly terrible diseases
can you guess can you give us a sense
though if if it were up to you to sort
of create a test or a question to decide
okay
eliminating hemophilia making someone
taller than they might be based on the
two parents that they have giving
someone better than 20/20 vision what
sort of questions could we apply to
determine whether a particular change
tutor should not be allowed or is or is
not ethical so at one end we know that
there are diseases that shortened
lifespan and really contribute to clear
dis phone
and by the way deafness and blindness
are on that list for me I understand why
people say they can exist either deaf or
blind and have great lives but it's
clear that not seeing and not hearing
these are dysfunctional States and we
could repair that very so better to be
able to do them than not do them it's
not part of the issue then becomes if
we're going to go after these clearly
dysfunctional clearly like shortening
diseases we better be careful to put in
laws that say we're still going to
support and respect people who don't
choose to do this remember it's not just
a question of where do we draw the line
what if you say I'm not going to fix
cystic fibrosis in my kid I'm gonna have
kids with diseases is the public gonna
turn around and say hey look you could
have fixed that you chose not to we're
not paying for your health care we're
not paying for any disability programs
the blames on you you want to have kids
that are sick quote-unquote not my
problem a big looming issue in a society
that's becoming more and more
individualistic but to answer your
question I think each case has to be
done on its merits you're not going to
find a single criteria that says ah
that's in or that's out somebody might
say you know freckles let's get rid of
them and I think it's pretty clear we
get an argument that says they don't
affect lifespan they don't affect
dysfunction they're just an appearance
issue or a preference we're not going to
permit changes that allow us to
eliminate freckling I'm sure people are
gonna look at albinism albino is an art
culture of predominantly white society
not really discriminated against not
seen as the worst thing you can happen
in a lot of societies Japan Africa
albinism is a terrible disease they
stigmatizes they want nothing to do with
it so I think it's going to have to be
case-by-case the burden on those to
prove why it is that they want to have
the disease eliminated that's how I
would handle it I try to do it with a
fair process not so much a set of
criteria that say if you fulfill this
you get it if you don't you won't
because I think it's going to change
from place to place and I think it's
going to change if you will from
economic situation economic situation
and so on absolutely fascinating super
important questions that at some point
will need to be answered we've been
speaking with arthur caplan director of
the division of medical ethics at NYU
Langone Medical Center thanks so much
for joining me again thank you for
having me